ايران هل كانت تحاول نشر التشيع في تونس
في فتره او زمن زين العابدين بن علي
في فتره الرئيس زين العابدين بن علي لاظن
العلاقات دبلوماسيه كانت
طيبه تقول طيبه ولكن في فتره برجيبه رحمه
الله
في اواخر السبعينات بعد عوده الخميني الى
طهران 79 79 وبعد
همم
اقامه الدوله اللي همم الاسلاميه الشيعيه
في ايران
كان في تونس في ذلك الوقت الاتجاه
الاسلامي هو الذي يتحرك التسميه القديمه
للنهضه للنهضه
وكان همم
يعني كانت الاوضاع في تعرفون السبعينات من
من يشبش نتعرض لها ولكن كانت هنالك ازمات
مثل
الاحداث 26 نجوم في 78
وكانت هناك اشياء مثل المحطه الانتخابيه
بتاع عام 1981 في اطار تعدديه وانا في
الفتره هذيك كنت رئيس قائمه للحركه
الديمقراطيه الاشتراكين في ولايه مدنين في
الجنوب التونسي
من من من اهل الحركه من
الذين انفصلوا عن الحزب الاشتراك في
الدستوري انا ذلك في بدايه السبعينات وعلى
راسهم الله يرحمه الاستاذ احمد المسيري
هذا ايران في ذلك الوقت كان المركز
الثقافي متاح من ال ال ال
الفضاءات التي كانت تساعد وتعين جماعه
الاتجاه الاسلامي في في امورهم
الاخوان في تونس
ان الاسلام السياسي قد يصبح يعني
انا اتصور في تونس اللي هو لسته
ويذاكرته هي الذاكره والذاكره وفيها
النسيان وفيها اشياء غير موضوعيه ولكن
شعار الاسلام هو الحل ظهر في الشارع
ربما رحلات الى اخره
الشيعي في تونس
وهو في التاريخ
مع الوزير